gangster grills G Perico
welcome first of all
things are going uh very well as I see
you have a brand new necklace that is uh
massive compared to previous Enterprise
click chains yeah Mark the the last one
is like just one of these letters
yeah
that's why I did it people was giving me
[__] about
I'm usually good at drowning out outside
noise but like I was getting roasted for
my you know because it was too small
yeah yeah
I usually I was getting roasted for uh
for my piece you know I was just keeping
it modest on the grind so let me just
how much was this uh
um it was it was a nice it was a pretty
penny north of 50.
yeah wow
you know you you strike me as the kind
of guy who doesn't do stupid things with
your money outside of buy cars
because you do have a car problem
yeah I definitely have a uh I was just
talking to my business manager I wanted
to get a uh Maybach the other day
and she like Mom you just bought the
necklace hold down this was already
coming okay okay okay yeah how many cars
you have now uh
I'm low right now I didn't did a lot of
uh flip totaling out some [__] Jesus
are you my license [__] up man that's
gonna say is it safe to say you're a bad
driver
who loves cars because I'm a bad driver
I just don't like cars yeah I'm not the
best driver
but it is exciting to ride with me
though that's one thing I could say is
it dangerous
no no no no no no no I mean the worst
thing that happened with me my lip my
tooth went through my lip and [__]
that's not too bad pretty bad yeah yeah
so are you currently allowed to drive
technically no hmm
so I don't drive right you don't drive
yeah the homies are off so who's uh you
don't you can't even get car insurance
if you want it huh I got insurance
in your name yeah oh I got an insurance
don't they usually like because how many
points are on your license
I'm I think I'm gonna point away from
just being like [__] up for a while
but I've been good all year so I'm
actually getting everything situated
this upcoming week so we gotta I'm gonna
be back good by Golden